[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais te donner la possibilité de
comprendre à 100% une r5
[Musique]
donc en fait tu peux lire du texte sous
moi quoi c'est ouf
si je mets du blanc ça dit quoi on s'en
fout
c'est le gorille moi je vois très bien
ce qu'ils voulaient dire avec son petit
on a oui bon je te laisserais bien une
fois tu est passable mais pas plus mais
c'est le sourire donc coincée du cul que
tu fais quand tu es mal à l'aise parce
que je met mal à l'aise je pense qu'il
ya ton mec que tu t'attends à mon mec
joue vraiment vous avez de la chance au
moins vous vous dites la vérité je
t'aime je suis moi aussi je t'aime moi
j'y vais d'associer la bourre pour
manger les machins que vous pas qu'une
agence calme bon ménage avec louise
pourquoi tu me l'a pas dit j'ai pas eu
l'occasion
[Musique]
tu aimes bien c'est bien ça
si vous voulez voir la série cliquez ici
c'est gratuit ah vous avez vu mais sous
titre là c'est ça oui ok c'est payant ya
plein d'autres séries il ya tout ça aux
parcs
oh bah moi c'est bien simple j'adore ça
south park